all right
peaches yeah my name is peaches peaches
peaches uh where'd you grow up where are
you from originally uh
california of california what part
northern southern northern northern okay
i'll grow up in l.a that's southern
oh okay so tell me about your childhood
you had both your parents
when you were young yes how was your
childhood
i actually had a white childhood to be
honest
i was feminist good childhood
no trauma no no abuse nothing like that
pretty good then
both both mom and dad were in the
picture mm-hmm
no mom she died but your mom died when
[Music]
um
then you were between six to ten how was
were you
i was in elementary school i had no
capacity but i didn't know anything
i don't even know
now you told me something on the street
about your grandmother was your pimp or
something like that
yeah so so when did you when did you
start working as a
sex worker 11 years old 11. how'd that
happen
sudden it's tragic stuff
like like what happened some
personal stuff i don't know that's what
we talked about here
okay so i'm not who where is this video
going to again
the entire planet basically oh hell no
so you got me up here looking like a
[ __ ] foe
and i already told you i just look this
up look at this
i want oh no everybody will see wait
bigger thing wearing it
ain't the hat oh it did this this
is you at least called a dp i mean
discipline honey
i think i'm talking to probably in the
streets i first call honey
what is hard for training for me
i get it easy because i'm young what's
the hardest part
period i'm gonna give you five minutes
of some real [ __ ] and then i'm gonna get
my money in bounce
okay perry that's here i was my name is
peaches i'm an og prostitute i've been
in the gang since 11 years old
my mother died two months old my
grandmother raised me boom denise
but you know what got addicted to black
tar heroin
at 14 years old from 14 years old all
the way up
i stopped school my aunt came
anonymous name and she changed my life
tried to
one it was there for me throughout every
separate way but i just was stuck in the
life of the game
because i never had really experienced
real life so i was just always hustle
hustle whistleblower
but then you know that but uh i'm 18
years old
my birthday's all my oh too much yes
honey
i'm born and raised in stockton
california my residency is
unknown because i'm homeless right now
and i'm 18. i try to get services but
nobody wants to help me
um i'm a prostitute i work on skip the
games and
i'm the hobby for many and right now i'm
just in a really bad mood right now
because i'm trying to uh because i'm i
don't [ __ ] with the police i don't
i'm not now at yeah i don't do it i
don't do it because
you mess with you either win the game
take those down the
this [ __ ] ain't easy nobody ever no
human being known as earth feel
comfortable selling anybody every single
day
honey i'm just not at the hospital honey
i have a stomach but one of my tricks
gave to me
and i had to have sex with him without
protection because
what it was either that or me fall
asleep
in the rain but yeah um
right now uh yes this is this is me
and you can find me i'll skip the games
i go by peaches but you can
gladly my phone number 209 306
four 4345 please do not call if you
think nothing
hold on you use drugs at all yes have a
seat
come on have a seat can i hear my pizza
i'll pay you a little extra oh sorry
action like what
come on uh crystal mac tell me about
crystal matthews
first time did it paranoid you know
hallucinate
you know that was found unresponsive
you could look me up on the internet
hey that's my real name yes honey and i
was
found i was found in the day
thank god i was tweaking remember my
husband's number yo
you've been arrested before yes i have
you been in love before
right now i don't really know what love
is huh honey because
anybody could hey i can make you falling
out right now
drop down to these knees and what please
you like what
because any man on this earth would
never pass that no
you know what but i'm gonna leave that
to the side because me as a person as a
who i am girl working girls
they risk their life every night out
here have you had bad stuff happen to
you
multiple times what kind of stuff
right yeah you when you come here you
experience right
abandon me rob kill
anything anything's possible in the
street when a night you know that's on
wednesday night
falls loneliness cause that's
honey well how i live this street i
don't walk the streets of fear
i want to shoot something that god has
when it's time for me to go it's time
for me to god
period but until then oh every night i
go out every day i wake up
this i okay peaches
girl you better give it a good one
because today might be the last day
i'm breathing in tomorrow's not promised
honey i died two times they came back
i'm here for a purpose anybody on the
street i take off my shoes for anybody
i brought booty butt naked and give out
who really need it at the end of the day
because i know deep down god is looking
out for me and he'll look after me when
i'm
i don't have to answer to him because
i'm i'm helping his people now i'm here
for these people i ain't here for you
you see how i look right now look young
but if somebody walked over right now
i'm dope sick
i would give themselves period because i
have a good heart
did you sleep at all last night no honey
was the time you slept well i was
well two days or three days but that's
not my that's my
like a little short one long it's not
been that
my last one was what a week and a half
because the crystal crystal keeps you up
yeah but
i've been laced with fitting all
multiple times sitting on the drug
that is like hair when it was just a
downer you were trying fentanyl or
you're not your background
lace with your hand because when you put
it when you melt crystal it turns yellow
but when you melt that video baby this
one's pretty
that you can kill yourself that way
yes i know yeah be careful i know so
what's more important do you love her
money
neither breathing is more important to
me
whatever the case may be i get a high
list baby so is that it because
my time is good because i gotta go
what's the most important lesson you've
learned
never ever ever
forget your self-worth and never my
advice to people
you live every day like it shall last
don't ever ever ever underestimate
yourself don't ever say you can't
when you and if you know you can't you
better make yourself
because of the night y'all say i've been
on this like this
all night long freezing cold jitter
no i'll be like oh it's hot oh it's hot
outside when it's
below train your thought
if you sad if you crying anything you
depressed sometimes oh honey
i was a self-harmer i used to self-harm
and not at psych hospitals cut yourself
but that's not okay
let's go thank you guys for watching
this video
you can find me and i on instagram
kellypeach kylie underscore dot peach
and on facebook
kim love thank you thank you peaches
yeah okay
[Music]
okay
okay
uh all right
you ready yeah
you gotta put your first down are y'all
leaving no i'm waiting for you to all
right click restarting
we're rolling so peaches tell me tell me
about your childhood
you've had some time to calm down since
this one
sorry uh you were wound up this morning
yeah
you know it's a lot and
my childhood and
some people look as they look at my
childhood it's like
terrifying and i hear from everybody who
hears my story
oh i would never look at you as the
person that
been through that or i would have never
known or
adults be like oh i couldn't imagine my
child going through that
they look at me such as a strong person
always got it together everything but
really deep inside
i hovered a lot of guilt and
responsibility for what i've been
through
um so tell me tell me the basics are
12 years old no i'm i'm going to get
there
so a little bit on me is
i was born to the power appearance of
angela and jason
um from what i was told my mother died
when i was two months old
and i was born and raised in stockton
california
there i lived with my grandmother
who raised me to the best of her ability
but it was a lot of complications i had
to grow up a lot faster
than a lot of other you know a lot of
other people
and a lot of other kids um my abuse
everybody says the whole trans thing
me become who i am if you're gay you're
gay if you
you know who you are you're not i'm i
hate when people hate it somewhere i
dislike when people say
oh uh where are you in the [ __ ]
there's not a
you're not i hate the question are you
were you how did you know how did you
find out
honey this your life is always written
out
there is no um you were born this way
yes
it doesn't just come along like
it was meant to be six years old no
honey but
i was molested on my 11th birthday by my
older cousin
um later that night um
this happened around moral morning time
actually and my grandmother left at this
time i was living in stockton on clay
street
my childhood home um
yeah it wasn't a home like it was a
crack house but anyways
um yeah i got raped
and it was kind of the most
uh terrifying thing that happened to me
in my life
but also the most
the most um formative no that's not the
word the most
like the best thing basically oh really
i look at it because
that just talk i really look at it every
night
it's not a day that goes by i don't
think about it because at the end of the
day
that's what revolved around everything
that night
oh honey that's the reason that i feel
like that's the reason me
my deep inside i feel like if that night
wouldn't ever happen
i'm gonna be here right now honey i'm 18
years old i just turned 18.
my birthday's on 902 2002 baby it's i
have no reason why
everybody i tell my age oh girl you're
not 18 you're not 18 you're not 18. stop
lying
i have no reason why i just act and
portray myself as an adult because
that's what i've
all i'm known to and yes i am a drug
user
my drug history started off when i was
young
i got addicted to black tar heroin first
i mean yes
alcohol you know that's a regular drug
that's
everybody is
acquitted to drinking alcohol and
smoking weed but nobody really knows the
hard more hardcore drugs like crystal
and heroin and party drugs
as in molly and lsd
and but me growing up
my drug of choice was
crystal and that
um i kind of i didn't want to experience
it but
you see my grandma doing it helping her
you know i learned to shoot up
at well not myself but i had to learn to
you know
because my gum would be too hot she'd be
too high sometimes so i had to
help her sometimes your grandmother
tyler after nothing it just you were
home
around this time i just started help i i
heard started helping her
around
third 12 13 but younger than that i
always
looked up what needle
put all needles together you know make
sure everything's nice and you know
i was like the second her like when she
is not at the park i'm
there to anybody because that's how
about the other day
everybody in my family everybody and
they look at my grandma as a bad person
because
my truth be told my grandmother was my
first pet
she was your pimp my first pimp
203 after my 11th birthday a day after
my left punch september 3rd 2002.
two or three honey i lived on clay
street in stockton california 95206
my childhood home clay street this way a
warrior street the back street
i started working the war it was my
first
that was my first brand i love you
um
my first trick i ever turned was that
at two or three next morning because
when i after my rape
i got a child she came home of course
i'm in there trying to
clean up everything and but i felt
my feeling that i would never tell
nobody but i'm gonna take it to the
grave because i believe that's what
happened i feel like
she was too high and set me up set the
right
i mean i mean i don't there's no other
way
you need to think about it but i can't
train myself to think like that but
that's just a feeling out of my head
because no who else would have known
that i was in that house
and how they know everything on but
aside from that my first trick was
turned on the warrior street
and all i could remember from it was the
blood
still but the pain was unbearable when
you
me 11 years old my anus is you know
these are this is a 18 19
20 21 year old me honey he went to
edison high school
and it's in high schools on chart away
my dog general
at this time his dick i mean his
genital was um
when i say larger like like growth
and me i never mind you i've never done
this before
never even played with that or nothing
like that never experienced any pain
like from the area except for that's all
i know to use the bathroom that's it
and it hurt
it hurt so bad like it like
like you just don't know like how bad it
hurt me as a person
like you i mean you it's like getting
burnt
it's like getting burnt or somebody's
like
putting that imagine you have a big
bowel movement
that you know that hurts like long and
that's somebody seeing a knife in you
just and you just have to sit there like
you wanna you wanna you're just fighting
and fine but you just at
some time you just give up you just
me at that time in the beginning i was
giving it all my 11 years old just
thumping
tense house and then
he got a hold of me and then it just
from there i realized
it was no more fighting i the reason i
screamed so loud nobody came
nobody came and it's kind of weird how
me and him was the only one in my home
when it was my birthday this happened on
my birthday
and i'm just like well you know when i
watch the streets now and all that i
just think of it
when i have free time i just like i'm
just trying to pick i'm trying to put my
my life story back together to where i
can make it make sense
because it's a lot of [ __ ] that happened
that happened to me it's still happening
currently where i can't imagine how i'm
getting treated like this when i
do all i do for people honey
living a life my life is not easy
after what brought me out into being a
prostitute
willingly to go out there is that
the fact that my grandmother was able to
do that to me
and everybody even thought it was cool
i felt the need that why not let
everybody know
and then cps got involved and
she got a parental rights taken and a
whole bunch of stuff
i got moved out of stockton san joaquin
county
but i kept going back why
the big question is why everybody why
would you why
everybody who helps me why would you go
back to that situation when i'm
trying to give you more i'm trying to
offer you to get out of that
the reason is
the reason why i come back to the
streets every time it's not because of
the drugs not because i can't handle it
not because i don't want a new life it's
that that's what i generated from
the streets that's all i know that's
what you know is love
that's what i'm i'm honey that's what i
know i that's where i feel the most
affectionate like
i'm got to the point where hey
i've been in the street so long that
that's my family so if
these bums out here if they're scared of
these bombs everybody scared of the
people
who tweak out they they look at look at
him he's nasty
feet dirty black but that's me that to
me that's
i look at them as if y'all look at your
colleagues that in a
billion million dollar business so if
prince charming pulled up in a
mercedes-benz and wanted to take you to
square life and
oh i'm gonna use that [ __ ] i'mma use
him for every dime he got
period stick to the game baby no amount
of money in the world no cleaning in the
world whatever
you'll be back to the stream because
this is this is guaranteed my life
my hustle is guaranteed but i only use
it to survival
right now i'm in survival mode if i need
if i can
go without like if i had me somebody who
would make sure i'm not
got my little dove and got me you know
clothes and clean
shower and everything i wouldn't do that
i mean
i would stay i would be with him and
stay with him
but i'm gonna just keep it real i
wouldn't be loyal
i'd mess with somebody on the side just
i'm just keeping it real
i can't be with the same dick all day
long same person
that's i get that up when i chose this
life i gave up talking to
get reaching out to certain people when
i chose this life
i gave up my family relationships
i gave up true friendships
i gave up my my self-respect my level of
self-respect
i gave up hunger i
you know when last time i ate honey
i eat candy that's my thing candy
that's what gets me going candy but and
crystal man
oh no let's not get things to keep me
going candy crystal meth
i need reason why i keep alcohol and
chris warming
crystal to keep me up and alert
alcoholic numb me from the coldness
honey it's stuff i gotta deal with every
day out here
people want to kill me people
honey i'm home in oakland richmond san
jose
stockton
you hear the man outside y'all
understanding you know no
i don't either guess what i heard
peaches
so obviously when i go in there i'm
gonna have to deal with something so
when i go in there i'm not gonna have my
shoes on
because you see my feet like this yeah
crest to that dirty and [ __ ]
peeled up skin and not taken care of
right
but you see my eye part
nice right you're beautiful right right
nice right
any day right i will take off my shoes
honey i can care less who comes up here
at the end of the day as long as this my
love documentary thing gets out to
other people i don't i'm to be honest
with you you can keep your money i don't
do this for the money
but you give me money i respect that
because you know i'ma have to need it
but guess what
hold on hold on keep it rolling because
this is the real this is my feet
i'll be down in a second i'll come down
here all right
stephanie come here
girl stephanie get in here parking lot
stephanie get your ass in here
and she thinks there's a problem
stephanie come here
stephanie tell her stephanie
what come here
now i'm going shut that door sir shut
that door real quick i'm going to the
lower tenderloin to get my cousin
hold on hold on that's not needed that's
what that's what you understand
you look how little white friend on the
bicycle
the little [ __ ] scrappy looking dude
who they [ __ ]
is getting abusive with me trying to get
me this is what you have to understand
if he hits me
honey they're not going to hit you with
me honey do you know you've seen me in
action before over you think he's my
brother's got a lower tenderloin
okay listen you have to no hold on wait
hold on let me do the interview
girl wait don't hold on wait okay
i see that you're worked up right now
but you have to understand
what we're doing right now you see we're
hoes right
yes so you have to stick to the game
we're not supposed to be talking to
people like this
we're doing this to help the other
people to let
people know the rail will go on behind
closed doors
but we're risking it and so are they but
listen when you pull the risk out from
me
and apparently he was apparently looking
for you or me but you already know how i
go down for you
that's what he told me was to bring you
your [ __ ] but you know how i go down
you know how i go down with you right
when have i ever let you uh
when i rather than anybody lay your
hands
that part here's your suitcase that part
all right i'm gonna go sit on the back
steps
okay all right
told you right i said something when i
said something
i said something but your instincts are
great but guess what
so you're talking about your feet and
your shoes oh i'm taking them off you
know what because
ain't nobody i'll be damn if honey this
might touch her
the fact and then that i took under my
wing
you see that the officer that's my she's
been wearing my hugs
all day every day i didn't i know she
got her own clothes
she got a place to sleep at night i
don't but at the same time
i'm willing to give up me and my safety
for her because any day if when i die i
want everybody
in the [ __ ] world to know that i did
everything i did
to not change everything but to make you
feel comfortable with yourself because
when i'm out here i want you to be
resilient but i'm uh my feet look it
blisters is red honey your feet are much
better than most
and i have to keep it i don't doubt you
work your ass off
but um the real honey
the pain comes from within you have to
trust yourself
if you're scared walking that street
you're not gonna make no money if you
don't make no money you don't eat you
don't sleep
me i can't sleep
i've been up two weeks and counting 14
days
today is my 15 day if i make it that's
why my
if you look up closely in my eyes
they're going like this
jittering jittering genuine you look at
my skin
i'm ready now oh honey
i just got the hospital you know why
what's up a stomach bag honey
you don't always have condoms
but you don't always have a
predicament that you're in so you see
that
you have sex with this trick with no
condom or you don't have no place to
sleep when you're outside in the cold
where you can get wrecked and killed
which one you pick
you risk living with something or honey
i get checked it
honey i stay teeth white everything
honey no matter what i mean
but just know i would gladly do
something with that petition
because my health comes first if i'm
oh don't worry i'll be i'd rather live
with something then be dead and gone
because my work here on this earth ain't
done because there's somebody out there
still who need my help
who need who needs somebody who've been
through it who could who know
and experience it who can tell you how
to get out of it
and if you can't get out of it i'm gonna
show you how to work through it
but right now um i gotta use your
bathroom because uh
my stomach bug problem honey i don't
have no underwear but my stomach
is you constantly [ __ ] on yourself
that's right your talk has been amazing
but um you speak beautifully i'm gonna
give you my
number
you